hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to
pogo stuck we've made it to this
mustache looking lip
and that's good because what that means
is that i've made progress and that's
good
i think i don't know exactly where to go
from here
oh no oh that can't be good oh that this
this can't be good what is the wind
okay okay okay
[Applause]
it was i just started i didn't know
how could i have known
[Music]
oh no oh
frick i'm gonna delete the game i'm
gonna delete the game i'm just gonna
delete the game you know what that's the
only
logical response i think is just why
keep it why keep the thing that hurts
you
around you why would you do that why
would anybody do that
what the frick was that what
minuscule people what minuscule piece
of that mountain did i just grab onto
because i am struggling to understand
exactly what it was that i touched
that the game thought yeah give him that
because i'm pretty sure that's that is a
completely
oh my god
when i say remind me tomorrow
i really mean that
oh my god oh my god
oh no no no no no oh
my god oh my god
oh my god
god of course
oh no no no no oh my god
[Music]
i [ __ ] hate this game ladies and
gentlemen
i've officially given up i'm not doing
this anymore
i don't like it i'm not having fun and
since i'm not having fun
i'm going to cheat and i'm going to use
one of their cheat modes which is the
double jump and i'm going to have a
great time
using it because i don't
care anymore
still not good apparently this makes it
so much
easier oh my god it takes some getting
used to to understand
how double jump is going to change the
game for me but
at the same time oh my god it's so much
easier
oh my god it's so much easier
oh my god i never have to flip again
oh i can flip but i don't have to flip
oh it's so beautiful
oh my god it is so beautiful
oh my god it's so much nicer oh but i'm
still terrible
but i'm not doing i've got
freaking cheats and i still can't get it
okay i just gotta i gotta use the double
jump as like a
saving grace okay not that apparently
oh my god oh god
i was just just just as bad
it just takes some getting used to it's
just i i just need to get used to it
because
it is a beautiful thing but my goodness
it can
it's a little tricky okay just go up and
up
and here and there here and there
no too far it's okay i'm up
boing
oh god there we go yeah that's what i'm
talking about yes
yes i'm here i'm back baby i'm
back i'm on a roll i'm back baby
i'm among the flowers again everybody oh
my god i'm among the flowers
oh no there i go through the gap
yes yes perfect oh my god
oh my god it's so much better
i'm so happy i'm crying i'm crying i'm
so happy
i'm so happy i'm back
i have the double jump and i still am
having trouble getting back to the point
where i
just was i think i i've earned this just
let me have this
i'm actually having fun again oh my god
please i'm actually having fun again
okay you know what okay you know what
i'm having fun again
here we go yes
okay so what is the deal with this wind
what
what are you supposed to do with the
wind
are you supposed to fight it oh my god
there's no fighting that
how would you fight that oh my god nope
okay how do you how do you beat the wind
are you supposed to ride it
are you supposed to ride it like to the
right to the right
point oh yes baby
oh yes baby where am i going why is this
all goopied
am i supposed to get on that oh my god
yes
oh no ah thank you i think what i'm
supposed to do
is get on here yes
oh god no i'm up
maybe ah man i never would have gotten
this
in a million years i never would have
gotten this you know actually i don't
even know if i need
that ah [ __ ] i do
i did i did oh wow this is super down
oh [ __ ] ah frick a hole
is this good bad i don't know if it's
good or bad was it good bad
good bad i don't know
oh my god oh my god b
b b
b i was supposed to do that with no
double jump
how would you ever have done that
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god this is unbelievable they
are joking they are so
joking oh my god they're joking a
million ways from sunday
oh my god oh my god they are
out of their minds these people
there's no way you would never
do that in a million years you would
never be able to do that what are they
thinking
i have double jump and i can see how
hard that would be
oh my god they're out of their minds
they're just straight up out of their
minds there's
no way no human would ever ever be able
to do that
ever
good thing i double jumped
oh there we go oh frick okay that's
just delightful this is tough
i don't know how i got down on those
bees on the first try but my god this is
absurdly difficult
without this double jump there's no way
oh my god you see jesus
ah fricka frack sassafraca frack a lack
of my fraca assa
okay where am i going exactly i think i
need to go
on the bees here
oh my god they are out of their minds
they're just plain old crazy oh my god
they are complete they're gone
they they're just they're they're
freaking gone are you
joking me
oh my god you gotta hop from b to b
climbing up the whole goddamn way are
you
joking me oh my god what am i doing
what am i doing i've got a double jump
how am i still getting frustrated
when i have a cheat code okay i'm gonna
do it the way they
intend hop from b to b
uh too much there we go and oh my god
that was a such a threading of the hole
interesting interesting
god i'm still not happy
[ __ ]
oh come on the [ __ ]
the [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god oh my [ __ ] god i'm just
guessing that they want you to boost
jump
it has to be right b to b with a boost
beat a boost on the b
yes that's got to be it and then i'm
recovering i'm recovering
oh i didn't need that damn it damn it
damn it damn it god damn it
oh my god oh wow
what the hell
[ __ ] i don't understand how they think
that this
is okay
you know what i'm gonna do this because
i can
because i got this silly boost i'm gonna
use it
i'm up here now oh god i'm down here now
oh god all right cool yeah you know what
that's fine yeah you know what okay i'll
go i'll go your way
oh no i won't no i won't no i won't no i
won't
no i won't what was i thinking no i
won't of course i won't go your way
of course i won't because your way is
impossible of course i won't what was i
thinking
i'm an idiot who was i even oh yeah
that's how i wanted to ride that
yes lose all my momentum oh i was hoping
that i was gonna lose that
i was like yes it's too easy with all
this momentum i better hope that someone
takes away
someone wise and understanding about my
predicament and my
situation and my mental well-being
someone who
really
[Applause]
someone who really
oh my god i've done that before oh my
god
stop being an [ __ ]
what the hell was that
oh my god oh my god
stop
no god why was i able to do that the
first time and now i'm never able to get
on the [ __ ] bees again
just what the hell this is just
unfucking believable
oh my god really
oh my god oh
here we go all skill baby
all skill oink nope nope
all [ __ ] skill
[ __ ] off hello yes b
[ __ ] yes b [ __ ] you are now my b [ __ ]
you are now my b [ __ ] and i
am a cruel mistress mr master
i don't know whatever
oh no no no no god damn it well that was
fun while last
okay that was not fun wallet okay
i am so mad i am so mad i'm
oh my god i've made it a little farther
so that's kind of cool oh is it up there
oh my god oh my god
really holy [ __ ] oh no wait
i knew there was no way there was no way
there's no way it was going to happen
holy [ __ ]
okay don't touch those got it duly noted
okay dooley ah
[ __ ] dance it's gone
okay
ah drama i am
so in control
in absolute control of exactly
where nope okay
all right okay yeah oh [ __ ]
me then oh my god
you [ __ ] almost did that to me
oh you [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] off oh [ __ ] off
oh [ __ ] off
oh my god [ __ ] off the [ __ ] bees
oh my god i'm gonna lose my [ __ ] mind
to these [ __ ] bees
[Applause]
oh my god where am i oh i don't know
where i am where am i going
i don't understand where i'm going okay
sure ah frick fruck frack [ __ ]
god oh hey actually
[ __ ] no why god
just [ __ ] leave me alone
oh [ __ ] god
[ __ ] dammit
[Music]
uh
thank you everybody so much for watching
subscribe for more
ring the bell to know what i'm uploading
and to appease my rage like the video
now and as always
i will see you in the next video
bye-bye